85 Google it 85 percent of millionaires
are married no that's good because that
means that they have a strong woman
behind them oh is that what it means
everybody
should we take way too much credit I'll
give you an example now Melinda
Gates and build
suddenly law
I'm not saying that the women have no
part to play what happened the
successful men are going to be
successful regardless when when Melinda
let's take um the Bezos Jeff Bezos and
whatever whatever
like he got richer she got poorer was
she that important
when it comes to his success was he not
going to be successful when raising the
kids
that's the point like behind every
successful man is not always a
successful woman it's a supportive woman